Professor David Blight:
There was trouble in the air.
I left you the other day with
Henry Clay sloshing down some
brandy on a late night in
mid-January 1850,
to try to come up with ways of
solving the great political
challenges they faced between
the sections and over the
expansion of slavery.
They were doing this,
in great part,
because gold had been
discovered in California.
This is an original photograph
of panners, gold-miners--white,
Asian and who knows,
probably somebody mixed black.
If California wasn't ready for
statehood in 1850,
it's possible there wouldn't
have needed to be a Compromise
of 1850;
but it was.
And already in its inception,
people realized how big
California was.
And they already realized,
North and South,
that part of it was north of
the Missouri Compromise Line and
part it was south.
Would that vast territory of
California become a free state
or a slave state?
The South's greatest spokesman,
its intellectual leader of its
states' sovereignty and states'
rights position,
delivered what became known
quickly that year as "The
Southern Address."
And in it, Calhoun said many
things, warning the country what
the South might do,
or at least the Deep South
might do.
But he captured it in this
ending of the speech:
"If you," and he's pointing to
Northerners,
"who represent the stronger
portion cannot agree to settle
on the broad principle of
justice and duty,
say so;
and let the States we both
represent agree to separate and
part in peace.
If you are unwilling we should
part in peace,
tell us so;
and we shall not--and we shall
know what to do when you reduce
the question to submission or
resistance.
If you remain silent you will
compel us to infer by your acts
what you intend.
In that case,
California will become the test
question.
If you admit her,
under all the difficulties that
oppose her admission,
you compel us to infer that you
intend to exclude us from the
whole of the acquired
territories of the West,
with the intention of
destroying irretrievably the
equilibrium between the two
sections."
And one of the oldest ideas in
our political culture is that
great conflict comes when
there's an issue around which
two sides--let's assume there
are two,
sometimes there are more than
two--but if there are two sides
on a great issue of conflict,
when one side or the other
cannot accept the result;
when a vital interest is
somehow at stake that they will
not, or cannot,
or choose not,
to accept a political outcome.
That's the question in the
1850s: can compromise,
some kind of coalition and
consensus around this question
of slavery's future--future in
the West,
future in the American
political culture,
future within the
Constitution--can some kind of
center hold?
Now, Clay invited Daniel
Webster to deal with this
because Webster's obviously the
most--at that point in time
Daniel Webster was the most
famous Northern Whig politician.
He was from abolitionist
Massachusetts.
He was anti-slavery,
though never a card-carrying
abolitionist to say the least.
He was a great lawyer,
many said the greatest orator
in the United States--those were
usually the ones that hadn't
heard Frederick Douglass yet.
He'd been in Congress since
1823, almost as long as Clay.
He'd been in the Senate since
1844.
He was seen in some ways as the
lion and the spokesman of New
England.
He had been the great voice in
the Nullification Crisis debates
of 1830.
He had been a voice of union
but also law enforcement
then--that famous phrase that he
had become known for,
"Liberty and union,
now and forever,
one and inseparable."
Webster always seemed to be the
union man, at the same time he
was an anti-slavery man.
Henry Clay from Kentucky;
founder of the Whig Party;
candidate for President three
and four times over.
The organizational genius in
some ways behind the Whig Party
and its so-called national
system,
the idea of using government
for economic and social change
in the lives of immigrants and
everybody else.
Clay of Kentucky,
slave-holder--he owned about 60
people--hemp plantation farmer,
original founder of the
American Colonization Society,
a border state political titan,
with great influence in the
Congress, pulls in Webster and
says, "Daniel,
we got to save the union,
because look what Calhoun and
company in the Deep South are
threatening.
What will we do?
How will we solve this?"
I mentioned the other day that
when Clay introduced his five
measures, which were known first
as the Clay Measures and then as
the Compromise Measures,
he stood up in the Senate,
with great theater,
and held a piece of what he
said was George Washington's
coffin.
What were the issues in 1850?
I hope you've seen enough of
the outline;
if not--it's gone for the
moment.
The issues are on the map.
The issues are that California
in the west is ready for
statehood, overnight,
because of that vast migration
of miners, by sea,
by land, and by imagination.
There'd always been a brewing
issue in the U.S.
Congress and in the District of
Columbia about the fact that the
District of Columbia,
the capital of the United
States, was a slave trading
center.
Northern congressmen,
of all stripes,
had always been bothered by the
fact that about 2½
blocks down the street from the
United States Capitol was a huge
slave jail.
People said that when the wind
was right you could smell it,
on the steps of the Capitol.
Abraham Lincoln in his one term
in the House called it a human
livery stable.
Foreign visitors would come and
they would say--they would stand
in awe at that majestic Capitol
as it was being built and the
dome was being completed,
and then they would ask,
"Where's the slave jail,
can we see a slave jail?"
So there were a lot of
Northerners now who were saying,
"Okay, there's going to be some
big compromise now about
California,
about slavery in the West.
What are we going to do about
this?
Let's deal with this question
too."
Thirdly, there was the question
of--and this is what Southerners
were exercised about--of
fugitive slaves escaping into
the North in that so-called
Underground Railroad.
And the term Underground
Railroad appears for the first
time openly, over and over,
in public debate on the floor
of the U.S.
Congress.
Southerners standing up and
saying we need a much stronger
Federal Fugitive Slave Act
requiring the return of fugitive
slaves because they are escaping
too much in that Underground
Railroad.
They didn't have a clue what it
really was;
didn't matter.
But Southerners wanted fugitive
slaves retrieved to them by law
under Federal enforcement,
no questions asked.
And then there was the problem
of Texas now.
It doesn't quite show it on
this map properly,
but the other day you remember
the map of Texas--the boundaries
of Texas had never been
determined--to the Mexicans,
much less to the Americans.
And the idea here now was
to--how would you kind of divide
up Texas?
There was no New Mexico or
Arizona yet, it's just this vast
territory called the New Mexico
Territory.
The idea was if you moved back
the border of Texas about three
or 400 miles,
and you placed it where it
actually is today,
you would open up new
territory,
lots of it, to the
establishment of at least one
new, if not two new states,
and those states in the
Southern imagination would,
in all likelihood,
be slave states--they were
southern.
What to do with the Texas
boundary?
Now, Daniel Webster's support
of this came at some price.
It came at a huge price for his
own career.
The five measures that came out
of their discussions--they
weren't alone but they really
did conceive this.
The five parts of the
Compromise of 1850 will be on
your citizenship test.
You shouldn't have U.S.
citizenship if you can't name
the five parts of the Compromise
of 1850--I've always believed
that--and the three parts of the
Kansas-Nebraska Act;
that should be a test of
citizenship.
No Lithuanian should ever get
U.S.
citizenship without being able
to name the five parts of the
Compromise of 1850.
Never mind.
[laughter]
California would be admitted as
a free state.
Clay said there's no way around
this, if they hold a referendum
in California it's going to be a
free state;
the people who've gone there
are all, they're all little
people.
There are all these miners and
these panners,
they're immigrants,
they're people from Germany
who've come across the sea,
all in one year,
to go find gold in California,
and they're not going to be
slave-holders.
All right, California will be
admitted as a free state.
But now, remember what Calhoun
had said--so what are you going
to give the South?
In return the South is going to
get a whole new,
much stronger,
Federal Fugitive Slave Act,
the most notorious and
controversial aspect of the
Compromise of 1850.
Secondly, Clay said to Webster,
"Let's abolish the slave trade
in the District of Columbia.
We have Federal jurisdiction
over that;
the Congress has jurisdiction
over the District,
let's abolish the slave trade,
let's get the slave jails out
of Washington.
Northerners will like that."
Webster said "Yeah.
Let's move the boundary back
three, 400 miles"--it was really
about 350 miles--"let's open up
a whole new part of the Mexican
Session,
with a possible establishment
of new slave states;
let's let Southerners dream of
two and three more states,
and four to six more U.S.
senators in the next three to
five years.
Let's let them feel secure that
California may come in as a free
state and get two new senators
and the number will now be 16 to
15,
free to slave states"--people
were counting.
The idea was "yes,
but maybe the South gets two or
three out of the Mexican
Session."
And then lastly how would
slavery be determined in that
southwest;
the big issue,
how do you do it,
by what principle?
Clay said popular sovereignty,
let the people have a
referendum and vote--liberal
democracy.
So that statehood for any
territory in the Mexican
Session, except for California
here--this is the stuff of
compromise,
don't look for hard principles
here--except for California,
everything else in the Mexican
Session will be determined on
popular sovereignty.
The people who settled the
territory at some stage of the
territorial process--it could be
early,
it could be late--will vote
whether slavery shall exist.
So look at the five measures.
California will be a free state;
slave trade--trade,
not slavery itself--will be
abolished in the District of
Columbia.
Two issues the North will like.
The Texas boundary moved back,
opened a new territory,
new possible southern states,
and that Fugitive Slave Act.
Two measures Southerners would
really like.
And by the way,
when Clay suggested the
Fugitive Slave Act to Webster,
Webster says "No,
no, no, I can't take that home
to Massachusetts,
it won't fly,
you can't do that."
Clay said, "You have to do
that."
Webster said, "I can't do that."
Clay said, "You have to do that;
have some more brandy."
Webster said, "Okay."
[Laughter]
I don't know how much brandy
they drank.
And popular sovereignty of
course, it's American democracy,
let them vote;
it's an appeal to both sides,
two for each side and one for
everybody.
It is a great compromise,
in a sense, but how is it
actually passed is crucial;
and of course its substance is
crucial.
The way it was finally passed
is that once--and by the way,
there was no certainly
whatsoever that this would work.
After Clay initiated the debate
with an emotional appeal for
union, Daniel Webster spoke in
what became known in his career
and in American history as the
"7^(th) of March Speech."
He held forth for three hours
in one of his classic
philippics.
It began with the famous lines,
"I wish to speak today not as a
Massachusetts man nor as a
northern man,
but as an American.
I speak today for the
preservation of the Union."
And he appealed to his fellow
Northerners to vote for the
Fugitive Slave--to vote to make
northern states legally
complicit in the return of
fugitive slaves in their
neighborhoods.
He got groans and he got jeers
and he got cheers.
Everybody said one of the
greatest speeches ever made in
the U.S.
Senate;
and it ruined Webster's career.
Poets started writing about,
as Wittier did,
"the Devil and Daniel Webster."
Calhoun was unable to deliver
his speech--it was the 4^(th) of
March--he was too sick;
he will be dead by the fall.
It was delivered by James
Mason, his colleague.
Calhoun was carried into the
U.S.
Senate in a chair;
he couldn't walk,
they literally carried him in,
sat him down.
He stared at his shoes,
while Mason delivered his
speech in which Calhoun said
that the South had to stand now
as one,
for a slave society and for
states' rights and for the
protection of what he constantly
argued were minority rights.
Calhoun's speech--arguably,
I think from an interpretative
mode now--frightened,
frightened--especially some
Northerners, into voting for a
compromise they hated.
It may have even frightened
some border state Democrats and
Whigs, to vote for this thing,
some of which they hated.
Like any great compromise--if
any of you have ever been on
major--political committees,
dorm committees and so on,
you got to pass something,
but you got two or three things
on the Bill.
And there are these people who
hate item number one,
and these people who hate item
number two, and these people who
hate item number three.
What happens if you vote on all
three at the same time?
Everybody's got something to
vote against.
So the way the Compromise of
1850 was passed--and it was
passed largely by the young
Stephen A.
Douglas, who took over the
management.
He was about 38-years-old at
this point, Senator from
Illinois, a young titan--small
as he was,
five foot six--a young titan of
the Democratic Party from
Illinois.
He was really the parliamentary
manager in the midst of the
debates from March into the
summer of 1850.
There were threats of disunion
from Southerners every other
day--brave threats in Southern
newspapers.
So what Douglas did is a
classic parliamentary maneuver.
He voted on each bill
separately and ultimately called
it the Omnibus Bill,
and in each case managed just
enough of a narrow
majority--getting enough
Northerners,
especially Northern Democrats,
to vote for that Fugitive Slave
Act, which they tended to hate,
and then just enough
Southern--what's left of the
Whigs--to vote for the end of
the slave trade in the District
of Columbia.
And it passed in early August
1850.
Henry Clay, ill,
terminally sick,
had gone home to Kentucky.
He'll be out of the picture and
out of American history before
the end of the year.
Calhoun was dying at that very
moment--was dead,
I believe, by September.
Webster was now to be denounced
politically forever in his own
political party and in his own
Massachusetts.
But the Compromise passed and
in some ways the nation
celebrated, or so it seemed.
The Compromise of 1850 did,
in some ways,
save the Union,
at least at that point in time.
But as David Potter,
the best historian of this
we've ever had,
said, it was far more--and it's
the best way to remember it I
think--it was far more an
armistice than it really was a
compromise.
It began to collapse almost as
fast as it passed.
There were huge rallies and
marches in northern cities
celebrating the saving of the
Union.
People were frightened;
I mean, business interests in
the north--not just in New York
City where the banks all were,
but now in this colossus of
Chicago, this burgeoning
railroad center in the West,
in Cincinnati,
Detroit--worried,
what if there is disunion,
what happens to the economy,
what happens to trade?
So there were great rallies.
At the same time,
the State of Georgia met its
legislature by December 1850 and
passed what they called the
Georgia Platform and sent it all
around the rest of the Deep
South.
And it said they--it said the
State of Georgia gave only its
conditional acceptance to the
compromise measures,
waiting to see whether the
North acted in good faith.
In other words,
"we don't trust you."
Some Northern State
legislatures said,
"oh really?"
And they passed resolutions
saying "we don't think we trust
you either."
There were vehement protests
against the Fugitive Slave Act.
The Fugitive Slave Act,
above all else,
in this crisis,
caused much further conflict.
It led directly to an estimated
20,000 African-American free
blacks--well,
free blacks and fugitive
slaves,
so many of them--living in the
northern states--and in some
cases, whole church
congregations from cities like
Philadelphia and Boston--moved
north of the border into Canada,
between 1850 and roughly 1857,
'58, when there was another
small wave, after the Dred Scott
decision.
This will lead now to
the--established in that
Fugitive Slave Act of special
Federal magistrates whose job,
whose sole job it was now--this
is a whole new level of Federal
adjudication of fugitive slaves.
Magistrates were now appointed
to go all over the north to
retrieve fugitive slaves--well,
to set up a police apparatus to
retrieve fugitive slaves,
and then to conduct courts to
determine their identity.
And in the Fugitive Slave Act
itself it determined,
or it said, that those
magistrates would be paid twice
as much money--they actually
would be paid $10.00 for every
fugitive slave they convicted of
being that person and sent them
back to slavery,
and $5.00 for every acquittal.
Now I know $5.00 doesn't seem
like much, but on the face of
that you look at that and think,
"Now wait a second,
this is blind justice--you're
going to give me twice as much
money to convict you as acquit
you?
Hey, I need a meal too."
It led now to famous fugitive
slave rescues,
like the rescue of Jerry
McHenry in Syracuse,
New York in 1851,
in a violent rescue by
abolitionists who spirited--who
killed one of his captors and
carted him off to Canada.
It led to the famous rescue of
Shadrach Minkins in early 1852
in Boston, a fugitive slave from
Virginia who was working in an
abolitionist coffeehouse in
Boston,
retrieved by slave catchers,
taken to a jail,
broken out of that jail.
One of the jailers murdered on
the spot by a mob of
abolitionists led by Lewis
Hayden,
himself a fugitive slave from
Kentucky, who lived in Beacon
Hill in Boston and dared Federal
magistrates to come to his house
and try to retrieve Shadrack
Minkins by putting an entire
posse on the street,
and a keg of gun powder in
front of his door,
which he threatened he would
blow up if any magistrate got
near it.
And that night they spirited
Shadrach off to Concord,
Massachusetts where the
descendents of abolitionists to
this day like to argue which
house he stayed in,
and then off across Route 2,
across northern Massachusetts
and on up into Canada where
Shadrach remained the rest of
his life as a grocer in
Montreal.
And there were many,
many other fugitive slave
rescues now.
There was a fugitive slave
rescue at Christiana,
Pennsylvania in 1851.
It was really at a farm.
A slaveholder named Gorsuch and
a posse of only five or six men
cornered a group of his former
slaves, four of them,
in a barn.
A group of abolitionists,
black and white,
defended them in a gun battle.
One of Gorsuch's sons was
killed.
The fugitive slaves escaped.
They ended up going across
upstate New York.
Two of them ended up in
Frederick Douglass's house in
Rochester, New York.
Douglass drove them personally
in a carriage to the wharf on
Lake Erie.
And when he bid them goodbye,
one of them gave him the
revolver that he had used at
Christiana, a memento that
Douglass kept the rest of his
life.
Resistance to slavery was now
direct, sometimes violent.
The Underground Railroad had
become an over ground railroad.
It was no longer caught up in
the romance of a whole lot of
people spiriting people to
secret hideaways.
It was sometimes now a matter
of gun violence.
And one could argue that the
most important thing to happen
in the wake of the Fugitive
Slave Act,
and therefore the Compromise of
1850, was the publication of
Uncle Tom's Cabin.
Harriet Beecher Stowe,
that brilliant,
very short, little woman,
who had lived for quite awhile
with her husband Calvin Stowe,
who was a theologian teaching
in Cincinnati,
had lived in a house on a hill
in Cincinnati for several years,
where she first met slave
women--where she first met
fugitive slaves coming through
Cincinnati,
and may have hid a few.
Heard their voices,
tried to learn their dialect,
and wrote the greatest novel of
the nineteenth century,
and still on any list,
any short list,
of the best selling works of
literature in the history of the
world.
That sugar-coated,
anti-slavery story of several
characters--Eliza,
young Eliza,
light-skinned with her baby,
escaping across the Ohio,
jumping from iceberg to iceberg
to iceberg.
The Ohio doesn't have icebergs
anymore;
didn't have many then either.
Or Uncle Tom himself,
the most important Christ-like
figure in all of American
literature.
Harriet Stowe wrote a brilliant
book, whatever anyone wants to
say about it.
She made everybody complicitous
in the slave story.
The most despicable character
in the book is Miss Ophelia who
was born in Vermont,
who's racist to the core,
who can't stand black people
and goes down South preaching at
Southerners what's wrong with
slavery,
at the same time she can't get
near black people.
And in some ways the most
admirable character in that book
was a Southern slave holder.
And actually the most evil
character--the most heinous
character is Miss Ophelia--but
the most evil character,
of course, is Simon Legree;
and Simon Legree was himself
from New England.
The whole world was suddenly
reading a work of fiction about
slavery.
It sold 300,000 copies in the
first year, by far broke every
sales record of any book ever
published, ever,
anywhere.
Reprinted into at least 20
languages in its first five
years of existence.
Made into stage plays within
two years.
It brought an awareness to the
slavery problem as never before.
And in the election,
the Congressional off-year
elections of 1852,
for every four votes,
for every four votes cast for
Franklin Pierce--the Democrat,
who will win--one copy of
Uncle Tom's Cabin sold
somewhere in the United States.
I mean, name a book today that
we could even imagine doing
that.
Would that there was a novel
[laughs]
that our electorate was
electrified by in some way.
Now, in the wake of the
Compromise of 1850 the country,
now though, had to face this
question,
not just what you're going to
do with the Mexican Session
territories--that's going to
take a little while.
Northerners,
a lot of Northerners are pissed
off about the nature of the Utah
Territory Bill and the New
Mexico Territory Bill,
because there are--Southerners
immediately propose slave
territories for Utah and New
Mexico.
But the real question,
by 1853 and early 1854,
was all of the territory that
was left of the Louisiana
Purchase--the Kansas and
Nebraska Territories,
which is simply what they were
at that point in time.
Now, it is worth stopping for a
moment to realize that not every
American woke up in 1851,
'52, '53, and worried every
moment of every day about the
expansion of slavery.
They are worried about it,
and it proves to us,
without question,
that there was a political
crisis abrewing that the
electorate cared about.
But it's worth remembering that
a lot of Americans were
preoccupied with the same things
they always were:
price of wheat,
a sick cow, wages at a textile
mill, a son who wants to marry
and needs land,
a daughter who wants to marry
an Irishman, or,
most of all,
all those Catholics arriving in
New York City and Philadelphia.
Huge numbers of Irish
Catholics--they're going to
Catholicize America,
they're going to turn every
small outhouse into a
confessional.
We laugh today,
it's easy to laugh at this,
but nativism caught hold in the
early 1850s--more on this a bit
later with the breakup of the
American party system as we take
it through the 1850s.
But a lot of Americans were
really worried about those
Catholics.
But the Kansas-Nebraska Act--or
the establishment now of the
territories of Kansas and
Nebraska and what to do with
them--was front and center on
the agenda of the United States
Congress by late 1853.
In the wake now of numerous of
these celebrated,
violent rescues of fugitive
slaves,
the attempts to enforce the
Fugitive Slave Act in some parts
of the north where it was very
successfully prosecuted,
and dozens and dozens and
dozens of fugitive slaves were
returned to the south.
But in some celebrated cases
they weren't.
Quickly.
The most celebrated case of all
came in the spring of 1854 at
the very time Congress is
debating this thing called the
Kansas-Nebraska Act,
and people are politically
waiting with baited breath to
find out what are they actually
going to do here?
We had the rescue in Boston of
a fugitive slave named Anthony
Burns, who was a young guy in
his early twenties.
He had escaped out of Virginia,
up to Boston by sea.
He too was working in--actually
a store at one point,
in a coffee shop at another
point.
He was even distributing copies
of William Lloyd Garrison's
Liberator.
He hadn't been there even a
year and slave catchers found
him, captured him.
Now, after Shadrach Minkins got
out of Boston in 1852,
the Anthony Burns rendition
case captured the imagination of
the nation,
because Franklin Pierce,
President of the United States,
moved Federal troops,
about 3000 of them,
into the streets of Boston to
guard the courthouse and to
guard the jail and make sure
nobody broke Anthony Burns out.
It became a test case for the
Democratic Party of
Massachusetts.
And on the day Anthony Burns
was marched--he was
convicted--marched from the jail
down to the wharf and put on a
ship back to slavery in
Virginia,
the abolitionist community,
black and white,
of Boston and all of
Massachusetts,
gathered in Boston.
They held an all-night vigil
with candlelight outside of the
jail and they draped the streets
of Boston,
or some of the streets,
in black crepe,
in mourning.
Burns was sent back to Virginia.
His story is amazing though.
His owner then sold him--he was
too famous--sold him to North
Carolina.
And one day a white woman in
North Carolina wrote a letter to
her sister in Amherst,
Massachusetts and said,
"Helen, that slave named Burns
that they captured up in Boston,
he's living on the farm next
door.
Isn't that interesting?"
And her sister wrote from the
First Baptist Church of Amherst,
Massachusetts,
back to her sister and said,
"Really?
What if we could raise some
money to purchase him?
Would you talk to your
neighbors?"
She talked to her neighbors.
One thing led to another.
Abolitionists,
beginning in Amherst,
Massachusetts and then around
the State of Massachusetts,
raised the money,
made the offer,
and Anthony Burns' freedom was
sold.
And he came North, by 1856.
He first arrived in Amherst,
Massachusetts where he was
celebrated.
They took him out on the
road--Exhibit A.
Then he went to Canada,
and he died in 1860 prematurely
of disease--lonely,
lost, almost unknown.
But it was in that environment
now, that Congress has to decide
what to do with Kansas and
Nebraska.
Now here was the situation.
It was in part a big deal
because what was firing the
American imagination now was not
just the west,
but it was the railroad west.
Who would build these
railroads, where would they be
built, and where would its
eastern terminus be?
Would the eastern terminus of
the transcontinental railroad be
in the North,
Chicago--or maybe St.
Louis, in a slave state--or
maybe further south in New
Orleans, or maybe Memphis?
Or maybe there'd be two of
them--maybe you could have a
compromised transcontinental
railroad built--two of them.
Well then people said,
"no, wait, it's going to be
hard enough to build one of them
over those mountains."
The Chairman of the Senate
Territories Committee,
a very powerful position in
these years, was Stephen
Douglas.
He's now about 40-years-old in
1854, a political genius with a
few terrible flaws.
Douglas wanted the terminus of
the transcontinental railroad to
be in Illinois,
in Chicago, and to go across
the north to the northwest into
northern California.
Douglas's approach to slavery
though is terribly important
here.
It is in some ways,
all of the story.
Stephen Douglas believes that
climate would solve the problems
of slavery.
He's famous for all these
speeches he would make where he
would say, "you know,
if the soil is good and the
temperatures are right,
then slavery will probably
exist.
Where the soil is not proper
and the temperatures aren't
right, or if you've got
mountains, slavery won't exist.
Climate will solve the problem."
Now wouldn't that be great?
We'll just lift--all of our
great political troubles are
just lifted off our shoulders by
the weather;
just watch the weather channel,
to hell with MSNBC and CNN and
all those blabbering pundits,
just watch the weather channel.
[Laughter]
He really believed that though,
and there was some reason to
believe it.
Now, the problem was,
Southerners wanted one thing
out of this and a lot of
Northerners wanted another
thing.
But here was the question,
which principal will you apply
about slavery in the Kansas and
Nebraska Territory?
Think now of the recent past;
think of the distant past--in
American terms--to the
Compromise of 1850.
One, had the Compromise of 1850
already superseded the Missouri
Compromise?
Think about that.
You had that sacred bargain,
they said, of the 36º30'
parallel line dividing free
territory from slave territory
forever, passed back in 1820.
That was that vow that
Northerners concerned about the
expansion of slavery could
always assume the great
northwest would be free of
slavery.
But half of California is below
it and half of it's above it.
Had the Compromise of 1850--and
half the Mexican Session is
above it, and now you've said
popular sovereignty will
determine the Utah Territory and
not the Missouri Compromise.
So which rule is in play?
Which principle do you apply?
Do you apply the oldest
principle of the Northwest
Ordinance from 1787?
The Northwest Ordinance,
folks, had said slavery shall
never exist in the Northwest
Territory;
which became those five states
of Michigan, Ohio,
Indiana, Illinois,
and Wisconsin--will never
exist.
Explicit territorial
exclusion--that's one principle.
The second principle,
geographical division,
Missouri Compromise,
draw a line across the
continent.
Do you go back to that one?
Or do you use the third one now?
The third one that's in
play--popular sovereignty--just
let the people choose.
Forget geography,
forget old laws,
and have a referendum.
In other words--and this is the
great question of the 1850s and
the terrible tragedy,
that, in the end,
nothing worked.
Would the American pragmatic
tradition now--yes,
we've got this-- we've got
principle A, B and C here.
We all want principled
politicians don't we?
We want principled professors
and principled politicians and
principled stockbrokers.
But, at the end of the day,
sometimes there are three
principles in play.
Would American pragmatism
continue to solve this one?
Well maybe that principle is
best now, but that principle is
better then.
Douglas wrote the bill,
the Kansas-Nebraska Bill,
as it was called,
or Act.
Now, in this case,
folks, numbers matter.
We're going to look at a vote.
But first of all,
he wrote three different
versions of the Kansas-Nebraska
Act--this is important--he went
from vaguest to most specific,
because Southerners put his
feet to the fire and made him do
it.
He first introduced a bill in
December 1853--this is for the
establishment of Kansas and
Nebraska Territory.
Everybody said,
"that's nice for establishing
these millions of acres and
square miles,
but is slavery going to exist?"
The first version that he put
before Congress on January
4,1854, said that a state shall
be admitted from those
territories,
quote, "with or without slavery
as their Constitution may
prescribe at the time of
admission."
Note the vagueness.
And you all know that in
politics sometimes the vaguer
you are, the more you get done.
"With or without slavery as
their Constitution may prescribe
at the time of their admission."
How that's to be done was not
mentioned.
Douglas said leave it to time,
climate, and good sense.
It was silent about the old
Missouri Compromise Line.
Southerners quickly reacted and
said, "Stephen"--his own fellow
Democrats in the south who were
now dominant in the South said,
"nope, not enough."
And there were a lot of
powerful Southerners in the
Senate.
So he drafted six days later,
January 10 of '54,
a second version of the
Kansas-Nebraska Act,
and he gave a direct statement
of popular sovereignty.
Quote: "The decision on slavery
shall be left to the people
residing therein."
Now he's moved one step further
and said there's going to be a
vote out there,
and however they vote that'll
determine.
Again, his fellow Southerners
said, "No, not enough."
And there's a famous episode
where as a kind of spokesman for
the Southern point-of-view,
a Kentucky Whig from the other
party named Archibald Dixon took
Stephen Douglas for a ride in a
carriage one day,
in March of 1854 after
these--excuse me,
in late January--they were
going to vote on it later in
March--but in late January,
took him for a carriage ride.
And Dixon in no uncertain terms
told Douglas,
"no, no, what you have to do is
you have to draft an explicit
repeal of the Missouri
Compromise Line,
a specific repeal of any
geographic division between
slavery and freedom in the West.
In other words Stephen,
you have to open up the entire
West to the possible expansion
of slavery."
Douglas didn't want to do
that--he knew this was going to
cause a bad time in the
north--and he is alleged to have
said back to Dixon,
quote, "By God,
sir, you are right.
I will incorporate it in my
bill though I know it will raise
a hell of a storm."
And he was right.
It may seem a bit odd to us
today that Americans could care
this much about what was to be
done to Nebraska,
[laughter]
or for that matter with Kansas.
We didn't even know about
Dorothy yet, and the Yellow
Brick Road.
But Northerners really did
care, because think back again
to this idea of free labor
ideology--and we'll bring this
up again and again in the next
three lectures.
The American Dream to the
average Northerner,
immigrant or not,
was land--free land if
possible,
cheap land if not--a place to
move to, mobility where you
would never have to compete with
any kind of oligarchy that could
control that land.
The bill that he finally
brought forth and that actually
passed had two measures.
And I'm going to leave you here.
The two measures were the
explicit repeal of the Missouri
Compromise Line and the
principle of popular
sovereignty,
the formula for the settlement
of Kansas and Nebraska.
The Kansas-Nebraska Act is,
arguably, the pivotal event
politically of the 1850s,
that will now sectionalize
American politics,
break apart forever the Whig
Party--what was left of it--and
give birth to the first
successful third party coalition
movement in American
History--the Republican Party,
immediately--which comes into
existence immediately--in the
wake of the Kansas-Nebraska Act.
And if you want to understand
how sectional that vote was,
write down that vote count in
the House.
Note, Northern Democrats split
right in half--that's Douglas's
party--but nearly half of his
own party in the House voted
against this bill.
Southern Democrats,
57 to 2--I can't explain those
two, I don't know what happened
to them.
Northern Whigs,
45 to 0 against this.
This is a polarization, folks.
We've heard a lot about that
recently.
Southern Whigs, 12 to 7.
The Whig Party is diminishing,
it's all but--it will be dead
in the wake of Kansas-Nebraska.
And the four Free Soilers,
elected in 1852,
on a platform that opposed the
Fugitive Slave Act,
voted, of course,
against Kansas-Nebraska.
That vote, 113 to 10,
got the Kansas-Nebraska Act
passed but in the long run with
terrible results.
It will break apart the
American political party system.
It will bring about for the
first time a genuine
anti-slavery political coalition
that will elect a president
within six years.
See you on Thursday.